you know in general i do want to
experiment with some different openings
to show you guys the range of
openings but we are white again so let's
put that discussion aside against the
2000 and let's once again play the
alopin
sicilian
[Music]
this guy plays e6 and d5 probably
okay a6 now that's that's a bad move
and once again as we know there are
several approaches we can develop
but what we can also do
is we can say you know what sir you
didn't play d5 i'm gonna make you regret
it by pushing our own pawn up to d5 why
are we doing this well
staking a bigger claim in the center and
stopping his knight from developing to
c6 now we don't need to play c4
all right this pawn is safely protected
by its neighbor
so we can just concentrate on developing
the rest of our pieces now
okay so he closes up the center using a
lot of time to do it and
that's actually not that bad of an idea
but he
hopefully we're gonna make him pay for
spending so much time
pushing his pawns around now black kind
of wants to play f5 here
and so so where should we deploy this
bishop
with an eye toward that where should we
move it to e2
no we should move it to d3 and then i
know that previously i said we don't
need to play c4
but here it might be a good idea to play
c4 in order to get get this knight to c3
but we don't actually need to do that
even now let's bring our knight over to
b to d2 thank you shimoma for the 300.
there's a very typical maneuver that
allows us to successfully deal with this
pin
and it involves the knight if you guys
play the rye lopez you should be very
familiar with this maneuver
what am i talking about where is this
knight going to go
it's going to go to f1 and then it's
going to go to g3
now that knight on g3 can participate in
an attack should black castle short
what it also does is it takes away the
h5 square from the bishop
now if we play h3 black must either you
know shoot or get off the pod bishop
takes f3
and in either case he gets rid of the
pin for us so we can breathe easy
okay
h3 it is
and uh again we have several approaches
approach number one is to say we're not
gonna let black expand
any further we're gonna make a move such
as b4
or a move such as a4 let's try that and
undermine
his pawns now look at what's going on he
can't move his knight out of the way
which why is that important that's
important because the rook what do you
guys notice about it
using our terminology what do you guys
notice about the rook
we're going to drop the bishop back he
attacked it is what kind
it is it's not trapped that's not really
the point there
it's undefended it's type one undefended
literally completely
which means we're threatening to play
eight takes b5 forcing him to make the
tremendously awkward move bishop
bishop takes b5 now his pawns are gonna
be horrible now we can complete our
development by castling
and uh look at this knight on g3
where should it go should it go anywhere
should we just chill on g3 what's
the idea
yeah that's right someone might have
absolutely let's bring it to knife f5
and now how about this bishop let's
bring it to g5 and now you guys should
start to see how we're accumulating
pressure on both sides of the board
but it's not actually easy black's
position is very solid in order to break
through on the king side we'll need more
reinforcements now when we need more
reinforcements we need to take a little
survey of our pieces to see which pieces
we can activate
now what do i see here these two pieces
are well placed
immediately i see two things that i
don't have three is doing nothing
and the pawn on f2 we would love to open
up that file as you guys are indicating
let's
kill let's do both things at once knight
h2 is a very typical idea in the rye
lopez because this knight
can come around to g4 in addition i'm
preparing the move f4 so we can
start by playing knight g4 and f4 is not
possible now because of the pin but we
can always move our king aside right
that's not a big problem so let's
complete that first maneuver and try to
kill off a defender
if he takes on g4 that will help us
bring our queen into the game
then the storm clowns will really start
gathering around black's king
okay so we're not doing anything
extraordinary we're just attacking in
very simple moves
with very very straightforward ideas and
hopefully he you know sort of starts to
collapse a little bit
okay so g6 a move like this that's made
on the on the side of the board where
we're attacking him
immediate question we need to ask
ourselves what new weaknesses are
created
as a consequence of this move and you
should immediately see that there's a
square on h6
which we can stick a knight in the trade
is good for us look at these dull look
at these dark squares
maybe one day we'll give a lobster
pincher checkmate attacks prepare slowly
attack fast
don't expect to checkmate him in two
moves i see this all the time players
get frustrated because it seems like
you're making no progress you are making
progress we are making progress it's
just slow progress
uh we've gotten the dark squares for
ourselves we've gotten some pieces in
the attack
now we sort of start to enter the final
stage of the attack which is actually
the sort of
you know now we got to start looking for
specific winning ideas
and if you look very carefully we
actually have a winning idea
how do i find it i would love to deliver
the lobster pin to checkmate you guys
should see that immediately right
it's such a common idea in order to do
that we have to get the night out of the
picture
let's get the night out of the picture
again we're moving upon in front of our
own king
which would disqualify this move for
some people but it shouldn't
because once again he's got no pieces on
the king's side there's no way he can
exploit this
i think he has to drop his queen back to
d8 then we're gonna take the queen
transform our advantage from an attack
into an extra
piece so the attack has succeeded i
think i don't see an option for him
and what he's done here he's brought his
queen to b6 that was his final that was
the nail in the coffin
because he can he could not have
afforded to just
move his queen willy-nilly away from the
zone of the attack but here let's be
clinical here's the thing this guy's
tricky
if g takes h5 he wants to trap our
bishop with g5 now we're easily going to
get our bishop out of there but i want
to show you guys what precision looks
like
can we avoid the situation entirely is
there is it possible
to just not have to deal with this
bishop yes it is a good job no he's
going to bishop b3
bishop e3 brings the bishop back
intermediate move
the knight's not going anywhere we're
attacking the queen okay
uh thank you for that now i think he
thinks he can trap my queen
because if queen g3 92 check is a fork
but the reality is we first of all we
can do even that and be up a piece
but we can also go queen h6 and save the
queen
and he resigns smooth game
game wasn't smooth enough and uh
relatively uneventful now
a lot of people as you guys can see
don't really know how to deal with the
elephant even at the level of
very competent 2000s so we go
d5 driving in the wedge we develop our
pieces we go bishop d3 to prevent or at
least discourage him from playing f5
now knight bd2 knight f1 knight g3 the
typical rye lopez maneuver
now we chase the bishop away undermine
his entire pawn chain here on the queen
side using the fact that the rook is
undefended
these are all very typical railopa's
ideas now what if he would have taken
the pawn
and crown jewels asked that at exactly
the same time what would we have done
had he taken the pawn
boom boom we've shattered the defenses
around this game but
at a grand master level by the way we
don't even need to
go around on bishop c2 bishop we don't
need to rush with this okay
and this is a very important point i
want to make
think of extra material as another man
on the
man on the soccer field okay 11 players
in a soccer game
think of extra pawn as okay one side is
10 players
but one side could still have lionel
messi and david beckham and whatnot
uh having a certain number of people on
the field doesn't win you the game
scoring goals wins you the game and in
the same vein
having extra material is a passive state
that doesn't in and of itself translate
to victory it might give you more pieces
to attack with
ultimately but you shouldn't immediately
panic when you sacrifice upon sometimes
you're just not in a hurry to recapture
it look at this fun
it's not doing anything eventually yeah
we'll go around and take it we can do
that immediately but we can also focus
first on developing
it has lots on absolutely okay i even
saw zlatan once he was in the same hotel
in
qatar during the tournament so here we
go knight f5 bishop g5 very simple
attack
knight h2 and i'm you know again
i can probably produce i can find a game
where you saw exactly the same this is
exactly what we practiced for exactly
the same attacking sequence
so i want you guys to look at this
sequence of moves
knight f5 bishop first the knight
transfer then knight f5 bishop g5
knight h2 knight g4 and then bringing
the queen in
okay remember and sort of hammer
this into your head for a second now
watch the following game
uh not a famous set of players 2150
very competent spanish master playing
white
1997 this is an over-the-board game rai
lopez
i want you guys to predict white's next
one two
three four five six moves five moves or
six moves
boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom knight f5 bishop g5 knight h2
knight g4 queen f3
okay in exactly the same order too and
then he lifts the rook
up and he crushes him with a very easy
tactic undermining than an f6
okay very specific knight queen f3 the
idea is to is to
x-ray the knight on f6 and you can see
the idea of queen of three revealed
on this move because the nano f6 is now
just busted
king h8 allows knight takes f7 with a
fork
g takes h6 knight f6 is the game is just
over
and black resigned because if he moves
this queen you simply have queen g4
and checkmate okay so i always get a
kick out of
how you know similarities work and
that's why you should keep your eyes and
ears peeled
for top level games because you can
learn about various tactical concepts
and ideas that
of course you can apply guys uh i i will
not forget the karakan please also be
respectful of the openings i decide to
play
i get you know i have the final say and
i'm capable of deciding so
i will promise i play the car con but uh
you know
i've i've noted that down okay so
basically we weaken his dark squares
queen h4
and now very simple right we want to get
this knight out of h5
in order to deliver the lobster pincer
mate and um
and and uh we do that by playing g4 in
order to chase the knight away from h5
what if g6 wasn't played well
um i don't really see what he can do
because
we want to play f4 not on the next move
that would be illegal
but we have several tactics here i mean
black's position is so devastated here
that
let's say he like plays a random move um
we actually can basically kill him
immediately could somebody name
the tactical idea yeah
actually this would be brilliant
no knight g7 is better i think knight g7
is better because it blasts open
everything if he takes with the king we
have a discovery against the king
we have a discovery against the king if
he plays bishop takes we have bishop h6
and checkmate is unstoppable
knight h6 has exactly the same idea he
can't take because of the discovery or
actually checkmate on f6
and if he moves the king then we wipe
the floor with him we can go back to h6
it's kind of like a windmill we're up
upon we have a massive attack
so you guys can see how when you have an
accumulation of pieces like this
you know the win is basically imminent
so queen h4
g4 and the game is over bishop b3 to
drop the bishop back
so that he doesn't trap it after g5
yeah so bishop d1 here would would have
the same idea as g4
but remember the rule when you can do
something with a pawn
you usually want to do it with a pawn
rather than a piece because here
if he goes queen to d8 it wouldn't make
sense to take the queen
right whereas if we attack the knight
with a pawn then we can take the queen
pawn takes the knight which means that
we're up a piece
so in any case well prime time you need
to figure out if you have tactics or if
you want to get rid of any of your
opponent's pieces that's what we did in
effect
by getting the knight to g4 we got rid
of one of his defenders
so anyways yeah the light squared
bishops were sort of chilling
on their respective squares but black
was the one uh who paid the price for it
black was the one what was the game's
accuracy yes let me look
uh i'm sure that you know inaccuracies
were committed
drum roll please 88.4
so but zero mistake zero inaccuracies i
don't really know
how how it was calculated so yeah i mean
he made us look good because no
basically most of the moves in the
middle game are all
we're all best moves yeah bishop e3 was
actually not even necessary
anyways um
let's play one one more yeah the uh
accuracy calculation i should say is not
like the end-all be-all and when
chess.com
investigates cheating people think they
just look at that number
and conclude on the basis of that that
is like the absolute tip of the iceberg
you know there's like much more complex
complex
statistics and analytics that are
conducted all right
so just to point this out to people okay
let's continue now we're probably going
to be black so
maybe i'll have a chance to play the
karo khan
no we're playing white again i don't
know why i'm white in three games in a
row and
sidsilian's ringing well we've been
doing well with the alvin and another e6
and this guy plays the same thing that
the last guy just played maybe he's
watching the stream maybe he's gonna
play the exact same game
okay this is getting kind of weird
i think he's watching the stream
yeah that's i'm pretty sure nope that
guy played bishop g4 this guy improves
with h6 if this is a coincidence
this might be the biggest coincidence
i've ever seen but we're not gonna
change our okay so he goes g5
all right so i think it's a different
guy now
the move g5 i see this often at at this
level
he's trying to intimidate us but what
i'm going to ask here is
which weaknesses have been created as a
consequence
of the move g5 and immediately you
should spot the f5 square particularly
in the context of the last game
so it makes sense to conduct the very
same plan moving the knight either to g3
or e3 even though we're not
dislodging a bishop from g4 now we're
accessing the f5 square whoa
okay so i'm going to make a very
interesting move guys
and i'm going to make this move first
and then i'm going to explain it later
i'm going to go knight to g1
and after the game i'll talk about the
concept of
retreating which is misunderstood by a
lot of people
what am i doing my end goal is to get a
knight to f5
and in order to get the knight to f5
well i have two goals first is to get
the knights f5 the second
is to open up the position because he's
moved nothing but his pawns
okay so i'm going to try to you know
accomplish both coals with my next
couple of moves knight's e3 now this
should make sense to you guys why did i
go knight you won
why the hell did i go at you could
somebody explain to me what this knight
could
possibly be doing on g1 i'll give you a
hint it's supporting a particular type
of move
it's supporting the move h3 which is
conducive to the goal of opening up the
center
or opening up the position in general
here the king side
and now we deploy the knight to h3 but
aren't knights on the rim grim well they
are
except this knight has prospects of
coming to g5 and i have succeeded in
opening up the atrial given the
sorry state of his development um this
is a
a a very positive thing and now my
second goal has been accomplished i've
gotten the other knight to f5
he can certainly take the knight but
guess what i'll take back with the pawn
i'll chase away his knight and and i
might even drive that pawn down to f6
now normally i've talked about this
before
you want to make sure that when you
establish an outpost on a square you can
recapture that outpost with a piece
but there are exceptions to the rule and
this is an exception because he's so
poorly developed
that what i'm just trying to do is keep
the flames roaring you know and keep the
position
as open as possible okay
this guy's actually not playing terribly
i mean his opening is not good but it's
not as easy to refute as it seems
okay alan t 17 17. thank you for the sub
what should we do look very carefully at
at the various sort of elements of the
position
when he's played in such a shoddy manner
we need to start looking for ways to go
for the kill
yeah we have a fork this is a type one
undefended pawn
right which means that we should
actually pay attention to it
particularly since we're making contact
with it
and we can just go around and take it
and normally i don't like to go pond
grabbing like this but we can
totally get away with it here because of
our absolute
domination development-wise and also we
open up the h-file who knows maybe one
day we'll checkmate them down that
h-file
um am i making a prophecy here well
maybe okay that h4 how do we deal with
this
how do we deal with this move which
again may look intimidating
but we can very easily shut it down
so we don't even need to defend the
spawn we can just move the pawn up to g3
and the check on g2 is not scary because
he traps his own knight he's gonna have
to
drop his knife back to g6 if i'm
considering this correctly
okay and now
let's deploy our queen and x-ray his
king am i worried about the knight on h5
i'm keeping an eye on it because it is
also a type 2 undefended piece
so if he dislodges my queen from f3 he
might win the night
but i don't see that happening because
of how passive he is
i just don't see that happening okay
um let me think for a second
what should we do well bishop g5
launders a piece
so we do want to develop the bishop
where should we develop it
just develop it to e3 right we don't
need to reinvent the wheel here we can
just bring it out and we can castle long
to link up the rooks which is what we're
going to do now we're basically ready to
start attacking on the king's side
finally we've completed our development
now we need to find a way to uh to get
things to get the
get things going okay let's drop the
bishop back he's attacked it
and this is no problem right again his
entire campaign
is running on intimidating us but the
reality is he doesn't even have any
attackers this move isn't even dangerous
so i know a lot of people want to go
king b1 or a3 we don't need to do any of
that we can basically jump right into
the attack against his king
with what move we have waited very
patiently
for this move to appear on the board
knight to g5 attacking f7 threatening
checkmate
much like in the last game if you guys
remember we kind of
goaded him into giving up control of the
dark squares
and that's an intermediate step uh
because that in and of itself is not
going to give us what is going to give
us checkmate now is a move like knight
f6
we're gonna we're gonna meet him on the
dark squares here might have six
if he had a bishop would have been
easier to defend now he's just
collapsing all over the place queen a1
check and always be shut down with
bishop b1 not to mention
that the king has an open escape on d2
so it takes takes
in fact queen a1 check he's probably
going to play
and what should we do should we go
bishop b1 should we move the king
okay actually here now we should start
looking for mates
let me think
hmm oh there's a very pretty idea
so we need to start looking for patterns
and first of all there is a piece that
we can put queen h5
is exactly what i'm thinking i'm gonna
keep this move shrouded in mystery
for the time being hopefully he gives us
a chance to uh to demonstrate a very
nice concept
but you guys can see how close we are to
delivering all sorts of mates
there's one particular threat which may
lay hidden under the surface
hopefully he gives us a chance to reveal
it
okay what should we do now queen king to
d2 of course
uh attacking the queen
and how and here we go guys
queen eh yeah this is again if you have
that notebook with the themes the
attacking
tactical themes this is something that
you should be very much aware of
uh i don't know exactly what it's called
but it's it's like an arabian mate or
something along those lines
no matter where he goes we checkmate him
where the knight in the rook come by and
the bishop
guards the knight nice little idea
checkmate we don't actually use the
discover check we just made them in the
same way
so nice hook mate is what it's called
very nice
okay so
a simple game given that he basically
did a lot of work for us i still think
maybe he was watching the stream
um but yeah so essentially
what happened so he went g5 and he
weakens the
the f5 square permanently which is why
this move is so terrible
and now we get the night over now knight
g1 right this move should make more
sense
uh should make more sense now um in in
light of
what happened in the game and so what i
wanted to point out is that
again remember the soccer player's
analogy right if you have
if you're down material that's not a bad
thing if the material you do have on the
board
is leonel messi type material the same
thing goes
here the knight on g1 is not inherently
bad because it's on g1
the knight is a very specific role and
that's why i always advocate to look at
pieces in terms of what role they are
fulfilling
rather than how they look or how many
squares they're controlling
it is true that when a piece controls a
lot of squares it's more likely to be
good than a piece that's not controlling
a lot of squares
but that's far from always the case
thank you so much mr alma i appreciate
it
and this is exactly such an instance
because the knight has a very specific
role
its role is to prepare the move h3 in
order to rip apart that h file
so that we have that artery eventually
to reach us king
two things first of all why is it
necessary to have the knight on g1 there
why can't we play h3 now
like can somebody explain to me why h3
is not as effective here
and um like why
why is h3 not effective here because
well because it's covered by the bishop
the file is still closed
one could argue that the g-file is open
but wouldn't you guys agree that the
h-pawn is now weak and
you know i kind of weaken my own king so
it's just not the same but there's a
secondary reason that i played nycha
which is that eventually
if h3 falls through if black finds a way
to stop it
this knight from g1 can deploy itself to
g3 and combine with the other knight on
e3
and then both knights would control f5
okay so it's kind of a
twisty little maneuver but sometimes you
need to go back in order to go forward
again i've written an article on this on
unchest.com
i have a lot of favorite examples where
you see moves like knight b1
um and and that's just a very
commonplace thing
very very commonplace thing the most
famous
example ever i would say of um
one second what was that game was it
rubenstein against let me try to
remember
the game i think it was ruben stein
against nimzovich
so very famous game 1926. nimzovich of
course both of these players
are kind of like the founders of modern
positional chess
and in this position nimzovich played
one of the most famous maneuvers of all
time
now i've hinted at what the first move
is but who can tell me not only the
first move but
what the idea is of this maneuver thank
you extrav
appreciate the 2am hype guys um
building our way toward
greater and greater hunts yeah so
nimzovich basically notices um
nimzovich basically notices the knight
on g3 and he says well
uh the knight on g3 isn't doing much
because i would love to put it on e4 but
but that square
is controlled i'd love to put it on h5
but it could get chased away with g6
and it's a relatively close position so
knights should be good in close
positions and what he finds is the move
knight to h1
and as the arrows indicate the knight is
simply going to g5 now
in getting there it's going to have to
pass some danger zones right first it
comes to h1 a very ugly square
and h3 also might look ugly because it's
on the rim
right but that doesn't matter because
ultimately
the knight is going to discover the
fountain of youth now in the actual game
because of the complexities of the game
he only put his knight to g5 on move 30
but it came with
tremendous effect and he swung his queen
back the rest of the game was actually
very pretty as well
actually tremendously instructed he won
a piece and then very fittingly
that night end of the game on a
beautiful no less beautiful square on c4
we can do a piece path
and you guys will see like all of the
nice travels but i'll do that later
the engine i think likes knight h1 i'm
not actually sure
but i think it's the top engine move and
that's the thing with these games
these players were not just like
randomly making these moves which we now
praise they were actually good
yeah so night each one is good it's it's
it's one of the top moves it's not as
clear-cut
as like as perhaps the commentators of
the day made them out to be
but from a practical perspective it's
still incredibly instructive
okay so not to make it big
not to belabor the point but just wanted
to indicate this and so here we go with
h3
knight is redeployed and the knight wins
us the game
okay it's the other night to be sure so
knight g7 check knight takes hy wins the
pawn
get out of here queen f3 deploying the
queen completing our development
we're not afraid of the attack because
black has simply no pieces in the attack
and now knight g5 immediately jumping in
with the other knight
so very similar to nimzovich right the
knight from g1 comes out to g5 it's the
same actual
it's the same square that's actually
kind of cool it's the same path
in the same square uh nimzobitro's path
was knight h1
um it was it was um
knight h1 f2 h3 g5 here we go knight g1
h3 g5 immediately so it's kind of cool
bishop takes takes dark squares are
weakened we swing the knight to f6
and using that h file and using this
very famous tactical pattern we deliver
the checkmate um okay
i i mean by the way the losses uh were
deliberate to stabilize my rating
one of them was against the cheater that
was my only quote-unquote genuine loss
and uh yeah so was the draw i think
any questions any questions on this game
this is made by the way also
usually people say that plans require
more than three moves shouldn't be
pursued well
i've kind of said that um i don't know
if it's like a common piece of wisdom i
know i've
advocated that to my students
uh so how do i know when to violate this
isn't this plan
like going to take forever so how do we
know thank you for the five bucks dumb
tweet
uh and again you need to exercise your
judgment
chess gape artist thank you for the tier
one and the reason that i think i can
get away with this is because
of what he's done in the opening he's
pushed only his pawns
which means that he doesn't have the
firepower
necessary to punish me and i can take my
time on something right
he's done nothing but weaken his
positions by the time he
he he completes his development that
gives me more than enough cushion
to orchestrate a plan that in another
type of position might have taken too
long
okay um
no i cannot beat stock fish eight and
neither can anybody
why not queen g4 instead of g3
so well queen g4 would have blotted the
queen right that's a it's a little botox
gambit
never travel or never win a chess
tournament again i don't know what to
think about that or upon only openings
that were viable yes they are
it depends so i can show you an example
in the alakine defense
if black plays knight c6 in this
position
now the main move is d6 knight c6 is a
big mistake white can basically win the
game
only pushing his pawns for the first
like five moves c4
d5 c5 and now
f4 and white is winning because he's
attacking this knight and
he's attacking this knight so there are
exceptions
but they're rare i mean playing an
entire five to ten moves without pushing
any pieces out
usually not a very good idea thank you
zola vagus you're
very welcome does that make sense
i've never blundered my queen in a real
game but i know
grandmasters who have um well queen h6
also was winning but
less less uh aesthetically pleasing i
would say
i don't recommend the petrov to anybody
below two thousand
i think the petrov is too dry
yeah queen d4 is fine
the alakan defense is more than viable
in fact i recommend it to some people
the alakan is a very underestimated
opening for club players
i think there are several chessable
courses on it as well so it's one of
those very cagey openings that can get
you a lot of good positions because
people don't study it as much
uh the perk less so because in the
alakan at the very least
black makes a claim to the center
relatively early in the perk you really
relinquish much of the center so
i think the alden is a little easier to
play for intermediate players